olivier dégâts saison
bonsoir olivier on connaissait leurs
batteries je connais laurent baffie ça
fait une paye que je vous attend sur ce
plateau je suis ravi que ça soit ce soir
merci d'être là veulent cacher votre
émotion mais moi aussi il me fait très
plaisir sinon je serais pas là vous
savez
alors dites moi ça vous énerve quand les
gens disent de kersauson les de dire
kersauson par exemple j'ai vu deux
kersauson hier soir à la télé chez
ardisson c'est vous énerve ça en général
les mules d'histoire mois que je joue à
bobo semaine et quand on vous appelle
l'amiral ça vous énerve non oui
on peut en général ça vient pas
tellement qu'on ne parle alors
profitez-en pendant un certain temps que
j'aime chez moi j'ai horreur qu'on me
parle je ne crois pas de ma vie avoir
adressé la parole en premier à quelqu'un
un but un peu timide réservé réservé
bien élevé vous porter un slip un
caleçon ou vous êtes toujours nue sous
vos jeans ça dépend les premiers
température produits pour le sud je mets
un slip fourré
en acrylique et dans les pays chauds
sinus aux mondiaux
car ce genre là messieurs
non
alors il ya au moins deux kersauson le
kersauson des villes elles kersauson de
mer on va essayer d'en parler ce soir le
kersauson des villes c'est celui des
copains de la radio de la télé de la
nuit moi ta [ __ ] sus tt et puis le quart
secondes de mer celui d'aujourd'hui le
grand navigateur qui a déserté un petit
peu depuis quelques temps le paysage
audiovisuel pour les horizons du globe
aujourd'hui en effet vous consacrez quoi
trente heures par jour au projet phare
de votre carrière alors c'est la mise au
point du plus grand trimaran à voile du
monde la course commence avant dé la
construction du bateau de la mise en
chantier d le choix des matériaux qui
sont souvent les décisions sont
irréversibles donc c'est vrai que ça
fait deux ans de de travail acharné
passionnant formidable
oui ce qu'il faut dire donc ce que dans
quoi dans un mois c'est le départ du
trophée jules verne il faut pas
confondre trophée et course un trophée
c'est un record on part quand on veut
alors qu'une course il faut battre les
autres quoi alors le trophée jules verne
ça passe par au mas par les trois caps
c'est quoi les trois caps cap cap town
fallu que l'afrique du sud 1 le cap
leewin au sud de l'australie et le cap
horn le bateau rendent en dans le grand
sud dans les quarantièmes rugissants les
50e et reste toujours cette zone là à
votre principal concurrent c'est bruno
peyron sur orange vous vous détenez le
record depuis 1997 71 jours 14 heures 22
minutes et 8 secondes six paires précis
et le bateau s'appelle geronimo lors du
pot parce que vos sponsors cap gemini
ernst & young schneider electric ils
vous ont pas obligés à appeler le bateau
car non au contraire il voulait il
voulait un
generix et c'était la première fois que
ça m'arrive est ce que alors geronimo
c'est un chef indien de la tribu apache
des chiricahua un qui a été traqué comme
ben laden par les américains sauf que
lui il retrouve la différence mais s'est
jamais rendu il s'est jamais rendu tant
gironimo une histoire de dom qui ne cède
pas faim et qui est assez qui est bien
et puis c'est d'une culture indienne
de d'avancé dans le silence pour
étrangler de de connaître son terrain de
connaître son monde de respecter son
environnement pour sens baba cool des
écologistes de merde d'aujourd'hui mais
dans la réalité donc avec de la
connaissance pas un discours fait mais
un discours de connaissances connaître
le monde avoir un véritable savoir et je
trouve que le personnage oui j'aime bien
et puis c'est un nom c'est un nom qui
fait rêver quand des petits et bien sûr
que quand commence est un peu grand ce
qui est mon cas bien sûr qu'on métier
les pièges dans les bois quand vous
étiez petit vous preniez pour geronimo
ouais ouais tout le temps tout le temps
moi j'ai toujours été dans ma tête un
indien et que sa fronde et ou alors le
bateau il fait 34 mètres de long 22
mètres de large le mafé 43 mètres de
hauteur ipes 20 tonnes 53 vaille 4,5
millions d'euros enfin si une opération
est proposé 10 millions d'euros c'est
énorme ils nous font confiance les mecs
la grève
regardez pas comme si on est chez sur la
moquette
le jeu c'est à dos mais pas dans tous
c'est un domaine dans lequel on peut ne
faire confiance qu'à remercie mes 10
milliards d'euros c'est beaucoup de pays
c'est le g le prix c'est le prix d'un
mauvais film moyen qui fera trois
entrées non mais c'est vrai tant que ça
finalement raisonnable c'est le fruit
d'une campagne de pub où vous trouvez
coincé entre canard c'est autre chose
c'est tout à fait baisser les bons
arguments je comprends comment les mails
ou les baratiner martin pas justement
moi je leur explique la réalité est en
général comme on parle à des gens
intelligents ils la comprennent leimer
sérieux alors ce bateau a été baptisé le
29 septembre par l'aumônier de la marine
nationale la marraine c'est marie
tabarly qui a 17 ans et qu est la fille
d'éric tabarly avec qui vous avez
navigué pendant huit ans un arrivé bien
ce matin moi j'en fais du trimaran quand
je pars en vacances avec ma femme et mes
enfants wen sur le mien vous pourrez pas
venir avec votre femme et vos enfants
afin qu'on regrette ouais c'est un vrai
bateau de course des paquets de mer à 40
noeuds
alors n'est obligatoire tout le temps
que le problème à ces vitesses là pour
le temps que le bateau fasse demi tour
s'il est à 30 noeuds le temps que le
bateau fasse demi-tour chances de
voilure pour affronter le vent ainsi la
39e c'est qu'on y est déjà du vent qu'on
récupère l'homme on est 20 minutes si on
est à 30 noeuds en vingt minutes on est
déjà rendu à 18 km de lui une tête
d'homme à 18 km c'est dur à voir vous
restez à bord alors 72 jours attachée
avec cas c'est pas 62 jours attachée à
ce son fils en effet dû gagner mais ce
que les mascaras elle est l'image ils se
sont toujours attachés je suis tout le
temps
en temps avec kersauson qui vous
critiquent en costume de bourreau voilà
sans alcool et en mangeant des sucres
lents comme bricaire ouais tiens il ya
des [ __ ] dans la cale ou pas du tout
rien pas de femmes à bord non
alors que l'on vous demande pourquoi
vous repartez vous dites parce que j'ai
déjà le record pour y rester à terre
vous dites pourquoi
faire l'amour alors qu'on a déjà fait
c'est même genre de questions idiotes
quoi bein si wes la réponse est
cohérente plus ce bateau est née de
l'expérience de la réflexion et du
travail donc c'est aller avec ce bateau
là aujourd'hui au tour du monde pour moi
c'est un bonheur un ce qu'on sait c'est
un bonheur presque grave comme tous les
volants les bonnes heures sombres et
léger donc bon on va vous suivre ici à
toutes les semaines on donnera de
nouvelles et tout ça on pourra vous
appeler au téléphone non non moi je peux
appeler mais on peut pas mon
métier on nous appelait faut envoyer un
télex d'abord il est parce que la télé
que ça clignote et vous le lisez vous
avez le temps de le relire on peut pas
m'appeler sinon je vais me transformer
en standard dit
nous apaiserait des fois si je vous
appellerai si vous êtes gentils avec moi
alors donc maintenant olivier avec ce
geronimo vous allez vous lancer dans
toutes les grandes courses qui vont
arriver et je prends
la route de ré
après le tour du monde on descend sur
l'australie on s'arrête un peu à la coop
américains ont tous fait le tour
l'australien on remonte sur hong kong
pour faire en kong londres après on
rentre quand londres de retour en europe
et ça se fera dans 18 mois à peu près un
pont ni ratio new york pour new york san
francisco on apprend en outre à san
francisco hawaï c'est vachement bien
fait partie pour cinq ans là oui
j'aimerais bien plus mais après je vais
peut-être trop vieux mais ce sont ces le
merci mais si c'est le sait la vie de
ces la ville peut pas avoir une plus
belle vie que ça donnerait 100 millions
de dollars pour arrêter de faire ce que
je fais je riais peut même monter adoua
double au triple je discute toujours pas
est ce que toi tu penses que tu mourras
dans ton lit ou sur un bateau suis pas
pressé de coûts que ça soit ça sera pas
une bonne nouvelle pour moi donc je m'en
fous a priori mais je
je pense j'ai pas envie de mourir non
même si j'ai pas peur non plus je me
demandais si comme les comédiens grand
comédien qui souhaitent mourir sur scène
je vais demander si les grands marins se
frotter à mourir dans l'accident de non
non non moi je veux pas mourir du tout
on va parler de la vie alors
[Musique]
or d'avoir ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que kersauson ça vient de care saxons
c'est un nom de guerriers envahisseurs
et gérez vous avez une âme guerrière un
peu comme ça c'est assez héréditaire
d'une certaine façon non noyade d'après
ce que j'ai compris devait être pas trop
délicat mais c'est sûr il y avait pierre
saxons alors vous vous êtes issu d'une
famille catholique conservatrice ski
pour des bretons est assez normal en
bretagne c'est commun voilà alors vos
ancêtres avaient acheté à louis saez le
manoir de keroual et pourquoi vous
l'avez plus aujourd'hui ça appartient la
ville de brest ce que j'en ai un autre à
côté qui est mieux avant plus marquante
est une autre question
alors bon il faut savoir que les
kersauson ont participé très activement
à l'histoire de france il y avait un
bien avant louis saez y avait un quart
sauzon qui dirigeait la flotte qui
emmenait saint louis aux croisades
robert de kersauson à sa statue au cap
parce qu'il s'était engagé dans la
guerre des boers parraine de
l'angleterre il n'aime pas les anglais
ils habitent à los angeles il est entré
de los angeles
et j'ai installé en afrique du sud pour
pour taper deux langues le pape et de
l'anglais voilà et votre nom exact c'est
kersauson de penan bref voilà exactement
alors cette septième d'une famille de
huit enfants rachitiques jusqu'à l'âge
de 10 ans
à cause des privations de guerre alors
c'est vrai quand on voit maintenant on
se demande vous êtes bien bien rattrapé
ce qui est faible et souvent mal un bref
alors tout jeune vous êtes déjà en
décalage avec votre milieu familial
problèmes à l'école vous fait onze
collèges religieux ce qui est quand même
beaucoup à vannes par exemple est resté
douze jours 1 alors vous chahuté pas en
fait vous réfugier dans le silence dans
l'indifférence qui brille plus énervant
évidemment pour les curés qui vous
surveille
vous réfugier dans le silence vous
évader dans le rêve dans la lecture
entre 11 et 17 ans vous lisez un livre
par jour
eh bien vous arrivez au bac et là vous
dites quand je serai moba que j'avais
payé mon tribut au corps social
et vous jurer de ne plus jamais faire
que ce qui vous plaît oui vous avez
jamais été en fac quand même qu'elle est
enfin qu il y avait le prof d'économie
qu'était le droit ouais il avait une des
chaussures à semelle crêpe à l'époque un
costume pas tout à fait neuf et le mais
qui attendent n'expliquait d'économies
je me disais à 100 c'est une arnaque
totale s'il a compris celle ci l'a
compris l'économie doit pas être là donc
je vais laisser mes bouquins au vert je
suis partie en moins mauvais de ce truc
alors voilà donc là vous découvrez la
mer c'est vrai que j'ai commencé à
barrer à la trinité sur mer sur le conte
bronn de jean marie le pen devrait s'y
révèle il y avait à l'époque il y avait
très peu de bâton à la trinité sur mer
et j'adorais ce bateau j'ai commencé à
naviguer avec tout ce qui traînait
l'époque moi j'ai fait tous les bateaux
de la trinité sur mer et même parfois le
soir on savait que les propriétaires
étaient à paris on les reconnaît pour
l'espionner ce qui aujourd'hui ont cela
nous emmènera directement en prison le
pen comment il était à l'époque assez
sympa en plus c'était à l'époque où il y
at-il à la guerre d'algérie ce fini
c'est moi j'avais un frère qui a fait la
guerre d'algérie les nos aînés au sens
large du terme n'a été
on avait des morts dans l'algérie dans
des parentes et le côté à l'époque
l'ancien baroudeur qu'il était l'ancien
légionnaire le rendait pas déplaisant
qu'ils étaient peints c'était sûrement
pas le profil du mec s'est tenue à
l'époque c'était un mec tout uniquement
révolté que je serai sympa c'est ce que
dit claude chabrol c'est qu'on est
l'agent institut la révolte qui
deviennent au dieu à caen sadien
un système de marketing dans le sait
quelqu'un qui crie parce qu'il n'est pas
d'accord avec son entourage c'est
toujours émouvant retour que quels
qu'ils soient alors donc après ça c'est
la mer pour toujours un vous dit si je
n'avais pas été marin j'aurais été marin
voilà moi j'ai quand je disais sur le
sur l'eau tous les jours même si on
appareils pas avec geronimo ça
n'apparaît pas avec alchimiste moi je
prends un zodiac je me promenais sur le
jeu chaque journée j'y prends un bonheur
alors que dans les autres métiers
donc il ya bien des moments géniaux
quand vous êtes avec tabarly que vous
découvrez le soleil de minuit pendant le
solstice d'été voilà le soleil qui
descend vers l'horizon comme ça qu'ils
tangente l'horizon puis qui revient
formidable c'est génial non mais je suis
retourné depuis sous parfois le soleil
donc refuse de se coucher parfois c'est
vous car là on a parlé du caire sauzon
de mer mais aussi le kersauson des
villes alors c'est jacques martin que
vous avez rencontrés à bora bora ouais
je passais avec un bateau à bora bora
lui il était là bas avec une histoire
triste et ne sais pas je n'ai rencontré
chez elle même pas qui c'était ce que
j'écoutais pas la radio j'ai jamais
écouté la radio de ma vie et en
polynésie devait trouver assez drôle
c'est comme ça je devenu copain avec lui
alors celui qu'ils aient ouvert ce quoi
c'est autour de 73 les portes de l'epr
de castel elle est partie depuis 69 et
c'est lui qui bat trouver un job que
cache-t-elle rooney son bateau donc j'ai
commencé à travailler sur le bateau de
castel antibes et puis a commencé un
marais aussi ouais alors un nom plus
tard vous décrochez votre premier grand
sponsor critères un john et skipper à
votre tour et puis jacques martin vous
présente à bouvard il a eu beaucoup
d'importance pour vous jacques martin
finalement énorme ouais moi j'ai connu
un individu d'une grande culture d'une
grande intelligence et d'une drôlerie
extraordinaire vous allez voir en ce
moment téléphone de temps vraiment il va
moyen très difficile de
son déficit de reparler à la des gens
qui est qu que la vie pour les avants
médicale à plus ou moins exclu d'un
monde
c'est déjà j'adore ce type mois sauf un
c'est un grand personnage si nous
regarde nous regarde bref
donc vous entrez aux grosses têtes au
début alors vous tourner le dos au
public par timidité c'est énorme ça on
fait de l'art à lyon ce n'est pas de la
télévision donc et puis aussi bien c'est
un travail donc autant rester concentré
avec les gens avec qui on travaille mais
pas de gros moyens de concentration donc
alors une fois que vous prenez bien soin
de répéter que tout ça c'est pour gagner
votre vie pour gagner de quoi naviguer
et vous avez même déclaré je fais cette
émission comme je conduirai un camion
poubelle
qui signifie deux choses la première
c'est que j'ai pas dis respect pour le
fait de conduire un camion pouvait ce
que c'est ce que j'ai fait que moi je
suis aux états unis et ensuite c'est que
le lol
aucun travail n'est une onde donc moi je
n'ai jamais pris de plaisir à le faire
parfois parce qu'on est il y avait de
bons copains ou contrariait que joe rien
ou sébastien où le luron martin on s'est
vraiment marrer mais le
sama si pour la moitié de ce que je
touchais s'il allait accepter que je
vienne pas se rater
alors là vous développez dans les
grosses têtes votre personnage d'ours
mal léché qui fait de vous une star en
fait une star des médias un ours mal
léché avec un caractère de cochon et
vous dites souvent vers le premier
contact me dérange toujours ouais hein
avec les gens comme ça c'est un peu faux
que je vois les gens trois fois pour
commencer à être à l'aise avec ces au
troisième le premier contact me gêne
toujours oui c'est la 3 4e fois je vous
vois ça va bien la madeleine mais c'est
vrai que c'est la culture bretonne c'est
pas très affectif ya pas beaucoup de
familiarité là pas du tout il ya un
énorme quant à soi un énorme on ne
communique pas
ni ses émotions et on ne parle pas mais
c'est une vraie culture c'est qu'on ne
parle pas on ne commande pas on ne se
plaint pas
ça n'a pas que des qualités ça les
qualités ça valait que je vois ça fait
aussi perdre beaucoup de choses fortes
émotionnel réels qui sont dans la qui
sont devant nous et que et dont ne
profitent pas faute de savoir les
utiliser c'est un peu triste aussi
c'était pas changé aussi j'ai fait des
progrès regardez comment je te sourit je
te brise rien je n'ai le rapper on est
huit amis nos vestiaires avant de venir
on arrive à la fiche 69 vous connaissez
le principe
c'est vous qui me posais une question
vous êtes heureux ouais ça va s'appeler
du temps c'est ce que je pensais ça va
alors oui c'est vrai que vous êtes un
ours mal léché la mère de votre fils dit
pour parler avec toi il faut prendre
rendez vous ouais ouais parce que la
plupart du temps c'est ailleurs quoique
sommes en train de lire un livre quoi un
peu chaud oui oui bah oui j'ai pas eu
des qualités mais j'aime bien sûr vous
me parlez dit demain 10h ce que je peux
parler avec toi les oui demain 10h donc
ça je me prépare psychologiquement mais
connaissant mais ferait le meilleur
coach je peux écouter si nous lancions
part je vais vous je vais pas écouté ou
je pense pas autre chose ça va me
déranger ce que je suis en train de
penser à autre chose lens est lui un
enfant qui s'appelle arthur avec la
comédienne caroline verne qui est
l'arrière petite fille de jules verne ça
a un sens et ça
c'était voulu ou c'est un hasard bah non
j'ai pas cherché cherche arrière petite
fille de grands écrivains pour reprocher
qu'on dit est absolument
j'ai fait quelques erreurs l'endroit
ça m'a vite gonflé j'ai toujours pensé
que non mais c'est vrai ya des gens que
l'amour passionne moi j'ai déjà aidé
tarbes à l'embl j'ai jamais mis un
disque de ma vie j'écoute pas de musique
je m'en passe complètement et mes
oreilles me servent à écouter ou dans
les bois ou sur la mer donc j'ai pas
accès à ça je n'accepte pas ça me gêne
pas bon l'amour il ya eu il ya la partie
romantique m'a assez vite échappé est
resté l'autre la partie fonctionnelle
donc le simulacre de la reproduction m'a
toujours intéressé énormément je le sais
que vous dites que c'est le seul moment
où on échapper un moment d'absolu alors
que le le
j'ai bien aimé la finale de la
reproduction en elle-même n'a jamais
vraiment passionné vous avez été souvent
quitter
pourquoi tant d'échecs au nom du japon
est un échec et équité au moins de trois
fois dans ma vie mais à chaque fois je
partais en l'air aussi dans quelques
mois je pratique est une lâcheté en
exercice et le fait que quand vous savez
que vous allez partir vous n'avez pas
besoin de recoller les bouts de l'hôtel
rapport c'est assez formidable aussi de
se dire bon temps elle me gonfle la
gonfle aussi mais toute façon dans 15
jours je suis parti donc c'est pas la
peine d'insister je vais de toute façon
faire aucun effort c'est un fait assez
délicieux c'est dégueulasse mais c'est
délicieux et jeu c'est dégueulasse en
fait c'est un faux misogyne suite le
paradis terrestre c'était quand eve
arriva et l'on faire c'est quand adam
ont pris l'habitude oui je crois que je
pense que ça en fait vous supportez pas
c'est la routine non mais je pense qu'il
le rapport avec il faut que toujours
considéré que le fin moi c'est ce que
j'ai cru avoir compris ce qui ne l'est
pas d'une grande intelligence et les
grandes puissances rassurez vous c'est
toujours pensé qu' il fallait prendre la
magie de l'autre ont elles passaient
dans son entité et surtout pas penser
que cette magie allait durer
alors olivier de kersauson vous êtes le
client idéal pour une interview alerte
aux roses
à lagord
c'est des petits jeunes allaient dakar
il ya un mouvement va s'élargir titre là
bien alors les filles vous êtes prête
interview alerte rose
olivier est ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de faire
l'amour pour aimer c'est d'une
complexité de trucks intellectuelle moi
j'ai besoin de faire l'amour quand j'en
ai envie ouais est-ce que vous avez
besoin de boire pour avoir cias
d'avoir soif pour boire c'est pas
du moment qu'on quoi voilà est-ce que
vous préférez une femme qui baissent
bien mais qui est infidèle ou une femme
qui baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
je crois que vraiment fond celle qui
baisent mal déjà elle sort donc le
problème réglé dont le seul crime est
bien si elle est infidèle c'est pas un
drame ouais c'est pas un drame voilà
vous préféreriez que votre femme couche
avec un autre en pensant à vous vous
couchez avec vous en france en un autre
je préfère qu'ils couchent avec un autre
gars là j'irai mais non on peut je m'en
fous non mais vraiment
vous êtes en train de me poser des
questions sur un très beau but mais
c'est les gars sont jamais posé
la main
en amour vous êtes partisan de tout
savoir ou de rien se dire
mais en plus l'amour étant pas
spécialement parlant pour moi je vois
pas pourquoi on saurait tout on dirait
quelque chose vous n'avez pas qu'on vous
raconte ces gens vient le mec était
formidable et tout ça c'est passé de
18h30 à 21h j'ai perdu les clés de la
voiture n'ont rien certainement garde
pas en plus j'estime que ce que fait
l'autre ne me regarde pas
vous voulez m'épouser maintenant vous
avez je pense qu'on serait tranquille
tous les deux vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec 1000 femmes toujours de la
même façon ou avec une femme de mille
façons différentes
c'est appétissant comme une pâtisserie
comme on accorde à 5 ans une femme fan
de bab toujours de la même façon et où
une femme de mille façons différentes
incapable de choisir avec eux
non non non je de toutes les façons avec
ma femme je vous sais pas je moi je
moscou et tout d'un coup jeunes
autant parler lui disant vous mais reste
de moins frais apparaissent je ne sais
pas si alors que c'est inepte donc je ne
sais pas je suis tout à fait perplexe je
réponds dans trois mois d'accord baker
d'agrément reviendra à son organisation
est ce que vous l'avez déjà fait dans
l'eau quand très très
souvent de la mer c'est quand même
pratique c'est la chambre d'hôtel la
moins chère c'est vrai le sel ça vous
irrite pas maintenant le salissent
dépose après un
préféré une femme comprend sans la
comprendre où une femme qu'on comprend
sans apprendre
fait prendre un gros pain dans ta gueule
c'est vraiment un du tout mais moi j'y
arrive pas vous m'excuserez le cher
thierry
pas à comprendre ces mécanismes
l'aménagent 5 on comprend déjà c'est
héroïque d'encre est resté en réalité
ici ou là si votre femme vous trompez
préféré que ce soit avec un homme ou
avec une femme avec qui elle veut
c'est son problème vous ai déjà dit moi
ouais l'autre fait ce qu'il veut ça me
regarde pas je vais quand même pas être
la péta carton rouge c'est une grande
aide non ça me regarde pas est-ce que se
faire sucer c'est tromper
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu